another edition of Nakamura's knockouts
so just like last time I did this so
first time I should say I think I'll
start out playing some some people some
of the fans some of the slightly weaker
players they don't seem to like Eric on
at the moment so maybe if they show up
all I'll play them as well but for now
all I'll start off with some different
people to start so I'll playing Neil on
duty to start or Dutta I should say
right d4 Knight f6 e4 probably he'll
play e6 yeah
NIMS oh maybe not an Enzo I'll play g3
so this is going to start as a Catalan
fish would be for Bishop e7 he's just
going to play classical I thought has
it's quite a few times is white am black
many different ways of playing it
probably he'll take on c4 here guess you
can play c5 - this is a slightly
inferior line but it's actually probably
going to transpose into something
different now it's going to turn into a
tirage a line thus far off quick played
quite quite a few times back in the 80s
all right 96
um what to play hero I'll try h3 just
basically I want to put a bishop on e3
stop any kind of Knight g4 tricks and
then I want to play against this
isolated pawn here on d5 or PA fish b3
probably developer crook c1 Queen d2 be
ideal
now after a six or a few way to play
this I think I'll try to play a little
bit positionally all exchange I'm gonna
Tate try and dominate on these dark
squares d4 c5 c6 could also become a
weakness here so let's see what he's
going to do right or p8
rook c1
so this would be 7 now I want to put
something else c5 but b2 is weak so I'll
play b3 make sure there's b2 is not
hanging and then next well move the
knight or I'll put a bishop d4 or c5
potentially both moves look reasonable
sufficient d6
I should be careful not too long to play
thematic sacrifice on e3 heroes worked
83 so put the fishpond e4 c5 Bishop b4
probably 94 355 looks a little bit
stronger to me optically basically
chased the Bishop from d6 so you go to
see $7 over should be for at 94 then I
get 95 word so I go Bishop d4 94-95
there are a couple exchanges that he can
you can try so we'll exchange I see 5
attacking the pawn on e6 maybe a 5 and
then e4 would be good um route b5 as a
move here as well basically I'm trying
to play against all these weak pawns in
the center where all my well Santa I
don't have any weaknesses either to e4
all right so we're p5 hopefully Queen
before protect a nice still can't do
anything here in the center
[Music]
so we're just going to do here Queenie
five okay reasonable move arm
guess I'll take maybe I'll take on d5
maybe playing action 93 this could be a
nice tactic here did now I'm attacking
the pawn on c6
so we're key eight if I take C since he
takes the four I want to play e5 fish
plus five so I'm not trivial but I'll go
forward anyway
ninety-seven Brooksie six and now if you
cake honey five I take a quark c8
probably there should be seven then
Murphy 6 or work v6 also move on all the
flavor of c1 double up can come up upon
and black pieces are pretty
discombobulated and doesn't exactly have
a whole lot of play here it's better to
try and exchange and now after work c7
he's really in trouble
bishop see it's the only way to protect
them bishop d5 and this is pretty much
over
and it takes five I'll take I'll take
probably help all makes it bad free move
assuming he'll take he's not watching
the theater he probably loose he's move
you're broken or something waited for me
to blunder rookie one bish buff one and
six maybe you can try to roll the deep
on but it's just a free piece should be
over take six and that should be game
get one all right so who knows um who
will I play next
what's it where all is all the top guys
we all seem to run away okay whitey God
alright good start to whites
okay so Bishop c5 I think it's supposed
to be considered dubious for some reason
commute for clean up six between g3
should be good Freud King updates also
move on this night f16 g7 and blacks
just lost queen g3 to go an 85 these six
and now 95 and now it's already probably
just lost
oops sorry about that I switch the wrong
screen wrong one sorry about that Queen
D 867
and let's see so I could take of any
butter
doesn't look like at all this grab 27
movie okay and I'll just take all the
pieces I assume is going to move a night
so I'll just pretty move it but this is
a private free probably takes
takes 55 a 497 Schneider 3
now it looks like penguin showed up the
one on normaly oh I might actually play
a few games now this I wish I had more
to say about the scandalous pretty much
just winning took a little bit hard on
the straight seven bishops five takes
probably Hill taking all the spread
around a pawn downs in this way all
right let's see takes and
all right climate challenge penguins see
if he wants to play or not you're going
to accept maybe not unfortunate Wow Wow
well he's not going to put it I'll find
uh hmm I'll find someone else okay um
maybe I'll try a little bullet action I
know some people wanted me to play some
bullet the first time around so you'll
play Danny run that would be an
interesting person to play if he wants
to actually play let's see oh come on
Danny you know you can accept Wow
oh this is very disappointing
so if I'm going down you don't don't
want to play all right um let's see who
else play well send out our challenge to
bond maybe maybe he'll play wipe them
off and blitz Navy wow wow
so right now I'm sending out a bunch of
challenges to see if anyone's an X but
so far none except I'm surprised it's
not for challenges so just kind of
waiting to see if anyone can accept them
um apparently not okay so it's a play
well I challenge all right let's see
okay oh wow play Wow
sorry about the slow time here just
going to anyone wants to play with it I
guess no once the top guys want to play
then all all the start playing against
everyone when just try two more
challenges let's see let's see okay so I
sent out a blitz blitz and a bolt
challenge of penguin sentiment bolt
challenge to Danny wrench put some pull
it okay so I guess yeah okay we're going
to go okay all pretty standard you like
to play this line for you frequently
Yuri see okay so far almost again all
pretty standard think I'm just winning a
pawn here maybe I'm wrong looks like it
at any rate maybe he'll play off five
maybe not okay trying to be tricky um ah
couple ways I could play okay I just
hang raphy one it's unfortunate
but I'm still in the game
or maybe I'm not I take this I'll go for
it why not
after why did I just do that let's say
maybe swindle him here I'm it's kind of
not what I just try and do but hopefully
at anyway yeah this did not work out the
way it's supposed to
ah let's lag what's going on here what's
going on what
okay that was weird I'm alright I'm
always to knock me playing bolt that
seemed to do some really weird lag on
that was weird
okay all right let's see I'll go back
swing blitz done wow wow
um alright I'll just go back to playing
blitz done because that was a little bit
silly I don't actually know what
happened there but somehow I timed then
all my time right now but his time also
was running one two so that was kind of
weird okay let's see so I'll play some
blitz then go back flying blitz okay
this should be alright so clean Enzo
I'll do what he wants to do okay is
going to be born play Queen c2 I have 3
d 5 4 C 5 so I'm pretty known 66
probably takes maybe rook d1 also move
alright work T one is definitely move
from cheese pies Queen I saw I see what
he wants to do here maybe H for a meaty
MC 6 maybe just fish me too but I think
I'm fishery to 90 Ford's is kind of
wrong half of all cakes probably he'll
take I don't really know what he's
playing for though just because I can
ever exchange really if he keeps to keep
the bishops on the board on his
reasonable attacking chances I mean just
because I've got this open King side a
little bit on 93 I've Bishop a5 my
governess like Queen takes a - maybe why
not I don't I don't see my queen getting
trapped here
I probably take I'll take Queen f6 clean
h5 looks fine
94 probably Queen safe or nice see sighs
you want to go Queen c4 clean off six
maybe takes Bishop d6 Queen h6 yeah
there there a couple different ways
playing I can also just like b6 maybe P
693 Bishop a6 probably not best on just
like play d4 also miss Bishop e6 or 97
many different options here but um let's
see okay nice if I seems like a bad move
for some reason but um I'll just play it
give him a chance to show the 0.3 that I
was not expecting however I think that
was probably bad no Queen a theory I
think I think clean a six was it was the
more challenging try now I'll have to
move the knight let's say 93 vishwas
five now I got the bitter to g6 on my
Kings side should be pretty safe this
place works e1 alerts their few moves
probably shouldn't say every single
moves out considering he's probably
watching the stream but let's see maybe
nice yeah 93 there's boss flies 95 take
so we want to get a Queen to f6 or
something like that but realistically
that's not it's not going to happen and
actually even if he does get that he's
still probably in a lot of trouble so
like I'll give them as Queen needs to
acknowledge go teeny h7 that could also
maybe play Queen b6 rook e8 sac sac
exchange and try to romp the a pawn so
that seems a little bit superficial
so obviously teenage southern we have
six Rick g8 and I'm pretty solid so he
could yeah of course can play with d5 um
to do it to go a5 or not to go I thought
that is the question
or roki eight all reasonable is rookie a
allows clean off six just for those who
are wondering so obviously I'll display
ripped gh is something simple safe make
sure there are no tricks over here my
king is very safe on h7 and hopefully I
can just run the b-pawn and a pawn down
the board don't really want exchange but
I'll offer the exchange probably they'll
take I would assume maybe not maybe I'll
try and play clean up six but clean up
648 looks looks pretty good now
and Bishop g3 how do I force an exchange
of Queens weenie seven doesn't work okay
I'll just play rook e6 make them go past
it because it wants to go roof d7 so
I'll try to make an exchange Queens now
and if you insist on keeping Queens on
the board now now I'm going to start
running the pods
okay that's still a move like a tinny I
don't have to take I kind of want to not
necessary at all here comes the cons I
know what's he trying to do maybe two
doesn't threaten anything oh and I'm all
the way down on time somehow so I'm
going to stop commenting every single
move that I play
so I tack upon again let's see what he
does
sly sly
alright let's say frustrating okay Chloe
you're not play good moves
Wow
so you think energy lagging are my life
okay um reasonable th1 Bishop g4 Bishop
g5 f6 takes Queen f6 Queen out 30 25 23
gosh it's probably is not so bad
actually looks a lot worse than it is
Queen 2 3 Queen e2 Bishop g4 which would
be to see what he's going to do you can
always take on V 2 V has doubled pawns
up here that I forget about that one
oops
but wait what 3 piece
that turned around quickly or ki8 um v1
takes I thought they went up six queen
out three cage for queen g3 okay so now
I plays with v8 now I can slowly start
to untangle let's see so I'll play
Bishop c1 seems reasonable
protect the bishop distancing over here
alright so h6
okay okay I'll try to exchange the
Queen's the Queen up for oh you want
some girlfriends surprising um play
rookie to take Bishop c7 looks pretty
good for c3 with pawn structures that
should should be very good for me on
because basically let's say okay what's
the way to do this construction so I'm
going to play rook e8 rook c8 and take a
cron that's the construction that I that
I need here so a forward six a three
work a six well I just take half 3a for
Bishop b4 now it's just boxed sex work
is six okay five and it's time to resign
okay for going to play the same line or
maybe I'll play Knight f3 I'm going to
play same thing probably Quincy to I
assume it's in close be the old old old
stuff too maybe I'll try to play
something a little bit more creative
today d5 is the modern in line these
days they're a few other lines as well
on c5 so what I'm playing now is
considered the old man why not remember
planets a lot when I was younger is
white specifically on route 81 that
seems wrong six is 94 if I remember
cross one takes Knight c3 takes rook
rook at the age of 95 or C
pretty even but still something I'm
presuming that you didn't actually look
at this line it's up 3 soon so I'll play
a six stop any 95 sub now and we'll see
five try to open up the Queen side a
little bit um from I came closer
Keeney seven or kc8 that's the perfect
harmony that I want so we'll see so
they're there this to the shop of course
is equal maybe be six is slightly weak
here if you can visit like DC by DT 594
although here I just Bishop C six other
words probably okay so it's 98 for now I
can play Bishop c6 here do I have to
play it maybe not but I'll play it now
it's starting to play d5 maybe but not
really shouldn't worrying me too much
salt is play 906 it plays d5 probably
all taking go Bishop d7 try and play
some kind of benoni structure on don't
have to probably well but okay so he
takes this was a classical game I would
certainly take the D pawn and make a
draw but since this is not like I don't
really want to take this pawned all I'll
do it probably because b4 but as I said
before this is not a classical game so
it doesn't really make sense not to know
I could play rook b8 I could take I
would I guess I'll just leave work be a
it's a little bit hard at this point to
not not be solved now if I take rookie a
rookie to in the nor k1 could be rather
unpleasant okay so it would be five to
fifty seven probably eighty four of an L
play a size and well let's see so okay
so he plays the e4 and played g5 maybe
that's one move here um
I think we'll play what well I played
fine I'll just play 98 f4 and what is he
trying to play e5 5.97 a good idea g5
fish + 3 6 46 46 P 1 or P 192 confined
to e5 take to be plays King out 3 FP v
VX I'm just planning to get this night
here at v6 OE 5 now I take I assume
he'll take on d6 maybe not ok if he
doesn't then all all this I might as
well premium te 5 because if you do if
you take bishop Donald's to take on e5
and we'll exchange everything then all
of 96 at the end she plays a d6
you take on d6 46 okay so probably he'll
take take 196 probably 94 not not
guaranteed 94 I also have rook c8 maybe
I could just take the pawn and I
probably close to draw though okay so do
I have to take probably I don't have to
take the pawn but it looks it looks like
the most logical move so it's going to
lead to some kind of 4 vs. 3 on game
here I think I take he's going to check
on the King f8 probably he'll take I'll
take so we're going to reach a 4 vs. 3
on game or not he's going to go a 97
let's see so if I go kini kini 8
probably works through 7 but what does
he have marrokal Chacon king g3 now if I
go 93 95 f6 looks good and so let's see
so play can't push and I tap Turkish you
to hang 96 is a move I can take the pawn
I I suppose not that I want to on King
up 395 rook c8 can be 7
that's four versus one is that enough to
win probably not actually I've got to be
careful again I'm getting too low on
time so yeah actually this this might
just be the simplest way to win mg or I
just check 95 second nope that's not
going to get it done kind of employing
people knowing that I'm streaming so I'm
lagging just a little bit because
otherwise it would probably just
resigned some of these solutions right
you can be six I'll play 486 probably
play a 5a flack take 593 queen bee for
work a for trapping the Queen so Queen
c7 keep on hitting the Queen I can take
here I can go Bishop a4 all all options
are on a table um I think I'll try
Bishop a4 just looks feel a little bit
more creative
d4 if you go to the trip g7 I'll
probably just take on the few team come
people now I can take on f6 I suppose I
can also just play Bishop d4e d4 on many
different off and Sarah licious see
I think here I will just I'll just take
with the pond we should be stopping
castles and play 93 just see what he
wants to if he goes Queen d8 I'll
probably came down see six place Queen
six which looks kind of weird also
Turkey one and now he's in trouble oh
now he's when he plays 94/95 if he plays
Knight loses night anywhere also just
take on pawn on d5 so we'll see um so 94
I'll take the pawn please work da I've
tied a six so Chuck and that should be
game over
I'm on time again who wants to do c4
Knight f6 or I wants the dish before
okay um trying to be like Magnus halted
b6 infinitum Magnussen's game against
Maxine Rashi legrasse and then blow
through Norway or something very similar
to that's at least nine out of 3d sighs
probably Bishop d3 maybe not
a 94
okay so c3 um I'll just play nice subset
on Queen c2 I can play off sides okay
look we need to all this council
probably Castle short I would assume
okay so he's trying to play something
weird it's like trying to outweigh me or
something I'm not sure what he's trying
to do I'm either he's going to put
something on e5 you can watch you know
if equals 95 I just take on g3 so if you
take I'll take look back at the pawn and
then you no longer it's a square on e5
um so let's see what he's going to do so
you're just going to Castle okay and now
I'll play cleanup six I also could have
maybe taken in fishpond g3 that was also
a possibility
um so c4 interesting now I'll take for
sure takes and I'll play c6 is always
there um maybe there are other moves to
I don't know if this is necessarily boss
I can play a six here but you know what
there comes a point in time now I'll
play Alta Asus with the intention
playing g5 g 4 and I played a six to
stop Bishop b5 so I want to take back on
d5 with the C pawn here so my next move
is almost certainly going to be like g5
g4 i guess i'll make the premium chief
eyes to four and now is the tough
decisions if you go to h4 is nice kind
of locked out for the rest again a plain
work out seven to solve any kind of
exchange back here so in case it eight
we exchange 93 play what do I want to
play I'll just play try to think your
first time so c5 really a threat or not
it could be I complete b5 don't have so
I could also just play something like
Knight up eight so that looks really
kind of ugly so um
I think I'll just play rook a7 basically
call is bluffing and out wait and see
what he wants to do in alpha King he's 7
or 9 f8 and goes play King to seven a
five note plays d5 and I'll call courts
into exchange and do something but see
here he is no entry squares on the C
file so in fact everything is very much
under control not complain itis 1896 it
was more or less my original idea a 95
Bishop a8 and again he has very nice
looking pieces but he doesn't really
have the squares for them - Bishop e2
I'll play 96 but now he's going to run
into problems here on the kingside most
likely on there should be seven make
sure you can't get them with rook c8 now
how to play this I want to take kind of
annoying
okay I'll let them in here and I'll go
work out seven and I'll try to do
something on the Queen side not the
Queen side sorry the the King side so
I'm going to go work h8 and cheese pie
that's my one-two punch g5 and Queen h6
now it's all over because again he has
no entry scores even though it's open C
file the bishops control all the
t-squares um now I have g5 I think just
winning the game hurts
oh we know he's 92 I should have checked
him first maybe I'm not that wasn't so
smart but anyway Ian goes on I'll take
we need seven maybe work h1 + f4 was a
little bit better maybe maybe on six
play Knight c3 I'll play Bishop b4 now I
will come but he wants to take on f5 if
you can't do that okay and I will play
c8 and Queen before try to force an
exchange of Queens now we need to Bishop
e6 give them work h1 if you want it I
don't have to all just play simple chest
now
and I'll blast it in the center because
t4 is coming and now he's got all kinds
of problems we take the pig with the
Queen I threaten me
as he moves tonight I stayed like on e3
we did so I'll just take that and he
doesn't remind ball swings pretty pretty
good option um okay works so well last
time I might as well go for it again ah
to place a six the way to stop the
supreme move I'll play c4 Knight of 6
I'll play something creative this game
I'll just take giving up the bishops to
ruin his pawn structure not necessarily
what I would normally do but seems
interesting enough probably Queen da for
Brooke c1 try to put some pressure on us
on maybe at some point I'm not sure if
I'm going to go Bishop e2 it he's going
to go Bishop he's going to go b6 maybe I
will go g3 we also go d4 or Bishop c4 a
lot of options here I think I'll just
play Bishop e2 and all this castle I'll
give them worksheet it I don't really
care if you want to do something else a
knight 84 and also fish + 3 + V goes up
5 I go g3 to protect the knight of
course I'm just trying to play along
this diagonal since my bishop is better
than his maybe I'll play d4 CD 4 92 or
94 put some pressure all over on his
piece on on the Queen side
so please work the 8 I could play d4
here play 92 also or your something
simple like a three all seem reason well
I think I'll just play a three passes
when I'll play 92 so it on 95 I can
exchange then I can play d4 in fact but
if he's going to go Queen seven I can
click b4 here or D for D for looks like
the right move
I'm work VHS Queen c2 all right I'm
sorry Queenie one Queen c2 you can take
fish from C 63 so Queen Queen e1 if you
take I take D 394 and I'm to subtleties
94 and what am I missing
what am I missing here survey says I'm
not missing anything apparently
right cleaning three I'll take change
bishops and Queen c3 maybe to pick up
the pawn yeah why not
this is also at some point if I pick up
this pawn which I can I don't have to
okay if I take e 592 Queen c1 e 595 easy
for you for even that's quite good but
there's no need to get into any of this
holds clear okay one Queen c5 I'll just
play Queen d2 so if you want to take on
d4 you can take on d4 I don't really
care because King will also be open once
this fish was off the board and if he
doesn't well he's probably just lost if
he doesn't do that maybe you can play a
five a five rook c1 but it's pretty
bleak all right so a a sighs the rook c1
probably clean d5 and now I'll play work
c3 just make and take on d4 work from
one and now it's looking pretty good
you know six so wants to go a v e4 I
don't have to let him get go for that I
mean I can play something else that's
just okay I'll just play rook c6 try try
and try and put pressure on its clean
side pawns because pawn d3
I can I can eventually round it up it's
blockaded it's not going anywhere so
Queen d4 I'm playing oops be careful
night of 300 is Queenie for so of its
Queen d49 of three Queen a 4.25 King a
big shock
King hhx a 95 does not seem right
okay so let's ask is Queen before
without any actual threat so I'll
regroup I'll bring my knife back now can
I have three a lot of Queenie for all
three group the other well maybe go to
f4 h5 try to mate in that way I'll just
come to e3 - its Queen e4 and now I can
take I don't have
- I'll just take and I'll just check and
I'll just tick of all looks okay let's
see so probably these 4 9 6 ok so it's
going to plate this up for gun um how to
play it's always just like I did last
game I'll just put a bishop on d6 put a
knight eyes gonna go see through here so
he's asking me to take because it's work
black and I'll play another Stonewall
maybe he'll take on d6 maybe he won't
need apparently once all 497 although
here we're leaving the bishop on f4 he
opens itself up some Chi 5 tempo and g5
s with tempo so 22:05 standard
a four I could try really be worried
about this I mean I know it wants to go
a five who cares I'm just going to
attack and mostly cheese five so he
wants to play this East five interesting
I'll just Castle if I don't have to take
on e5 generally in these structures you
don't want to take on e5 unless you're
forced to in here I'm now threatening GV
for undermining it's not a nice turn
that if you lose the night after three
four night news I just take on e5 two
times and I've upon if you take on d6 I
take with a pawn and I've already got my
king side pawns rolling so it's pretty
good
he probably will take though if I had to
guess maybe not
okay so it's it lets us told his plan
here
so you place c4 which strikes me as
being rather wrong I feel like there's
got to be a tactical solution here so I
take money five and he takes back with
the night I can take back our drive
let's play this club taking d2 instead
and now taking on e5 is correct
um if he took back I just take as nice
as any play Bishop b4 now the question
here is how to capitalize so I proceeded
on c4 I take on c4 he'll just take and
even though I'm a pawn and the resulting
structures you're going to get a nice EE
5 which is not really what I want so
probably I will take but how will I take
is I guess the question um Fe 4 seems
logical d4 also makes Sun I mean all
moons look pretty good here I just have
to kind of figure out which one to do I
will take with the D pawn plays d5 and
now we'll see se plays rook e1 I can
play Queen d3 I can just like Queen c7
also now if you plays Queen to 3 over 58
probably 91 only move here let's here's
where I have to figure out what the plan
is I can play up for I think I'll just
play Bishop c6 and prove the bishop make
some sense and now no just do something
over here I'll just kind of delay all my
moves make them wait okay a six to stop
95 play H four okay so actually that's a
bad move now he's going to see control
of the D file in fact actually why do I
live with it I could just keep that on
that's pretty pretty stupid of me but
anyway still a big clamp over here on
the Kings side so it's actually really
quite hard for him to play he's trying
to somehow survive this it can play a
five here I'm not crazy about arms I'll
just go work d2 though on Queen City
Reagan for Queen D 391 I think after
Queen e2 it's just is getting needed now
so that should be GG maybe we'll play h3
try to fight on another move or two but
in all likelihood this should be
cheating now hopefully Chi force I'm
turning me Queen up one g3 and actually
the whole whole board what kind of luck
for him so rather unpleasant okay let's
do it he'll do you got the third chance
to improve on his opening play okay so
it's kind of play the same thing
crawlies in 1916 a sixes um I don't
really want to play Knight history we
all do it Knight f6 put a three I know
this guy likes to put a bishop on a
cyber g4 so I playing a three I'm going
to stop them from doing next he goes
Bishop g4 I'll just take on c5 and then
followed up with b4 so that's the whole
point behind this a to remove as opposed
to playing some kind of normal
developing this it takes takes probably
six or Queen c7 I'll just take clean see
took is generally not how I play this
but I think this guy has played the
Petrosian system before with white and
it's kind of similar I would say I mean
Trojan system is via is d4 Knight 6046
Knight f3 b6 a3 and unusually black play
some d5 later on what an exchange is
knight on c3 there's about five
o'clock's see one like I said this guy
likes to put a Vishwanath 5 or chief or
if you can um so root d8 now I'm going
to go Knight f3 because if I if I can
get 94 and it comes with an extra tempo
then then I have to make use of him play
moves without developing anything here
on the Kings side
so probably bishop t6 maybe music
leanback at c7 good animate I'm liking
the position that I have so far I think
it's pretty good
okay it's a bish four so now I can play
ninety four ninety five a lot of
interesting options now they go to 94
you want to go clean see Sevenfold up by
e5 so I think it makes more sense maybe
to play safe or maybe ninety four point
c 7 c 4e 5 pen 9527 f3 val 295 and so
now if it goes Queen c7 all I'll play f3
kick the Bishop out of 4 which is why I
want Queen b6 now I can go clean before
again I can actually maybe go after 3 or
not F 3 takes push me to Bishop f5 not
really so I can play Queen d4 here but I
also don't want to really do that either
so let's color something
energetic and active here maybe there
should be four maybe not quite sure yet
or just be four maybe
yeah I think I'll just play d4 with the
idea that on e6 I can play c4 I'm
pointing that once you take that clean
a4 check or then es clean beside maybe
not Hawaii but if he takes maybe I've
edge schoo Bishop d4 so basically the
big try here is clean a porch at
Cynthia's know if blocking so I'll throw
on the check I have to go King f8 and
now let's see now how do i punish him
punishment pine probably I should have
played Bishop b4 first instead of
cleaning for track but easier said than
easier to see it after the fact so c5
Queen c7 probably I'll always play off 3
take the bigger back I can go c6 here I
don't have to but it looks like a good
mo so why not v6 now this munch pawn
and this is getting pretty ugly nur in a
hurry for a verb mr. penguin now here I
can maybe go clean b7 hmm not crazy
about it probably are other ways of
playing this so let's see I think I'll
probably just check poster on the check
here because when he takes I take Queen
b7 Queen b6 I'm up upon and he still
want to he one of Callias no
coordination or what this work on ehe it
which really looks kind of stupid here
and she goes there I think I can just
off I take you as work d7 so he does
have some tricks so up in the bag
so I'll just um if I play Knight b6
probably rook b8 and some kind of weird
counter play maybe maybe not at the same
time I'll just take it all just going
for an end game here and I've got an
extra pawn it's going to be it's going
to be a protected passed pawn in fact so
this is looking pretty good
so probably he'll take maybe not but at
any rate this should just be technically
winning I just said be careful about the
time situation here that's the only
really big issue anyway shouldn't have
any injuries out here and let's just
find the flag and first b5 was a bad
checkmate
okay so now is going to now actually me
will see if the Trojan system as I was
mentioning before where it's like a
train D sighs okay wants to play this
one so we'll see okay and here I can
Castle I don't have to I mean I know
Queen b6 is also and what its playable
but I think I'll just take on d4 and now
I will figure this out I think b4 is a
move 95 is also an h5 also is possibly
move on let's be a little bit careful
here so let's just be four isn't move
but natheless looks right on d5 i can
just take with a pawn so there shouldn't
be any any real worries that's what i
was really worried about if i please
like move like before then he would have
played d5 and we would have a very
strong attack and now he's obviously
trying to figure out if you can play d5
but I am pretty sure tin cannot play d5
here so so we'll see okay so you plays
95 on I can play h6 I don't have to I
would prefer to play something else
actually maybe like b4 b4 94 a5 maybe or
maybe just even something simple like
work c8 but rook c8 a lot of tonight up
7 me so I do it to be a little bit
careful here um I could play Knight e5
as well or maybe even just 95 and 97
seems to reasonable right off let's just
see it takes 97 probably Bishop f4 maybe
he'll exchange fish about for Queen c7
I'm pretty happy with what I've comps
shall be opening
okay there's about four point six seven
and now I want to kick his night point
95 B 4 B 4 right away even even just 95
here although I think I'll just put a
work on D 8 so that I can meet clean h 5
with night f 8 and then there are no
weak weaknesses over here on the
kingside takes I'll play work 58 and
whites maybe very slightly better here
but their relation should not be any big
issues all tonight s 8 if I can exchange
rooks especially there can never be any
real danger here and now with this
structure with this structure it's going
to be very hard for for white to deal
anything takes on the roof D 8 6 7 now
I'll try and gang up on this pawn here
inside if I can because basically this
whole King site here is very very stay
clear there really are no threats for
white so I should be fine
it's a Queen d2 I'll play something all
97 will - he's going to do I mean he can
you can always stack on h6 but it's not
going to leave maybe it's actually just
going to be a draw - Sakhalin h6 but I
don't think he has more than more than
that so he's clearly deepen even thought
it probably wants to do it but isn't
able to make it work from Queen City 3
so there should be 6 and now this e
flies on is frequently big liability for
for white in one Bishop T for now he's
and now he's in a lot of trouble
down to ponds on tonight a face protect
as long as I don't allow someone I still
attract me I should just be maybe not
winning there are still some serious
technical difficulties here but
significantly better at any rate three
and now a Quincy sized portion to
exchange for drop another pond basically
now the problem for him is he's down
it's not so many ponds that he kind of
has to go for go for broke and and so
let's so actually now now there is a
problem that he's going to have to
exchange Queens or exchange bishops and
bishops two laws and now I'll just
create a square for my king so I can
bring my knight into the game and the
rest should be pretty straightforward
actually I didn't have to hang that pawn
but which is lies okay so I think I'll
claim maybe two more games I think is
what I'll do two more and then call play
someone else now if it's essentially
five only one something a little bit
different the d4 probably takes or
alright takes probably ninety eight 793
so to Castle 894 it's probably is gonna
have to take on each side now
depending what he wants to do so we'll
see
submission G for playing I see forth
here on takes between us three he wants
to go defy that's right of course
closely - we - probably takes takes
takes 95 maybe um we'll see
okay so de5 now I can take on da work
the 895 may be a little bit weird I
don't know if 95 is right but it looks
494 I just if I go a 95 maybe he goes
night before that's the only only tricky
part or this which I completely forgot
about that was unfortunate you know it
was stupid okay it's not enough to just
like play passes castles 90 to try to
exchange in pieces since I played a
stupid move now the structure such that
even here you know I played a stupid
move and lost the tempo I can't really
be worse which is always a good thing
want to go for 95 here at some point
unless he's kind of let me exchange
rooks that I do want to exchange rooks
I'm just not sure how I want to change I
think I'll start with 94 put pressure on
this ePHI pod so you go to the h6 and
play a four I complete g4 also to try
and prevent aside from being a real
issue and I think I will actually just
want to lay off five I'll take take
Knight g3 and I kind of like this again
you can always exchange the rooks if you
want to
not that it much matters to me
ah so please be four okay so now I can
exchange I don't have to this is pretty
dry unfortunately let's see so I'll just
Chuck I'll put a knight on a 4 B 5 for
the knight back to d2 and then I back up
1 to g3 I'm going to go this way and
this is pretty draw I would say I guess
I'll try I'll try to create something
I'm not really sure what what I'm trying
to create but I'll try to create
something ok I just hang on over here
that was unfortunate but maybe knocks
I'm going to actually win a pawn on the
other side so even though I've blundered
importantly I'm still very much in the
game I don't 96 was that was so stupid
move
9 games are very tricky that's one thing
that has to be said um they're a lot
trickier than than people tend to
realize yeah I don't I don't see it here
so
now I say wants to throw my fine
okay so I'll play one more and that
should be good
maybe and maybe he won't the dish about
for probably some he will he does want
to fish or okay same thing we please see
for this time okay so trying to be
tricky here hopefully Bishop e6 try to
exchange the bishops lending way
probably different g3 is bust
maybe Bishop c5 he wants to play
something original so he did lose to Tom
phones it has to be said so this is not
necessarily the right way to play this I
would say you want to play a six to stop
95 and goes to stage 4 I don't know what
he's trying to do I can place these eyes
here I don't have to I'll just play work
see a that might have loud something
that I shouldn't have allowed with this
clockwise but it's a bishop g3 and I can
take or played expected I think I'll
just take all I'll try to play original
chests here with c4 d5 expand on the
Queen pipe probably in a normal game I
wouldn't quite play like this and the
probably are slightly better ways of
playing but I'm a game like this there's
no reason not to so I'll play 94-92 I
can play off five Taiwan to and I think
I will the thief I square is never a
real weakness here for me so it
shouldn't be a big deal and I also
threats like putting a work on each six
eventually and doing something I mean
White's problem here is White's very
cramped white doesn't have a whole lot
of space and why she's getting slowly
pushed back so here I can take with the
app calm which I might I know I'll just
take with the deep on the sep 3 I can
play this differently G for now that's a
strange move I was not expecting that's
all for you g5 and I have six I'm going
to play for some 9 to 14 h4 and some
neat stuff if I get the chance
kcg puzzle to work d8 queen bee for it's
not create an actual threat I don't
think that fat back for more
alright so it's going to happen so you
can play 90 c4 then I have work takes d5
on if he plays something else I'm not
I'm not really sure what else we can do
here maybe Queen d2 is a move maybe not
I'm not actually sure so work d2 which
is always a move now I can play work d6
maybe to try and meet him which I think
actually looks really quite strong now
oh it work HS is not neat what am I
thinking I'm crazy
oh that was stupid that was very stupid
incredibly stupid actually
oh ok nevermind wall that was weird
okay very strange um I don't know if the
law says I know what happened um King f1
was the right was not not g3 I'll try
and I'll try to watch I'll try to beat
him down two more times than I'll stop
as soon enough connection is decent
so
boss lady 5volts take on not I think the
best way to play this for black
generally at least it's not considered
to be the best way to play it because I
think White's
weight gets a big center here and it's
quite hard to block to play this is why
it also controls all the pawn breaks
here in the center - maybe he'll take
maybe he won't
I would assume he will take
okay clean v6 th one probably he'll take
now I would assume still he doesn't have
to take 93 for Oh 15 e1 probably now he
does now he doesn't elastics are
probably 9a for h3 also as a threat not
really sure he's trying to play this
tassel in a place that maybe wants to
play some h5 I'm not not actually sure
we try and do but at any rate we'll find
out in a few seconds 93 here probably
loose night a4 so you place a six is a
strange move so I'll play a three okay
so if he doesn't want he does want to
play for some some nonsense on the on
the Kings side on which is not really
advisable because like I can play g3
here maybe g3 actually makes a lot of
sons but it doesn't feel quite right so
if I'm not going to play g3 I don't want
him to gain anything pair I think we G 3
is illogical try basically I'm trying to
sit in like crew proof that you have
something over here on the Kings side
well I just keep developing my pieces
because he is king and a center both
works are undeveloped on and it's not
not exactly trivial to play it so there
should be seven I'll play Bishop d2
maybe now I'll move the knight and have
some Bishop a5 Turkey castle on the
Queen side he obviously can't cast on
the scene flex and I'll just take his
Knights who is playing g6 I think I'll
play 91 now of course he does counsel he
runs into fishery a5 immediately and now
he also can't really move his night
because the e5 pawn is too weak to be
decided just playing f6 which is hoof an
ugly-looking move on now the question is
how to take advantage because he's
clearly playing
suboptimal moves um so I can I can maybe
just move my knight I can also click
h4 maybe or 91 Knight f3 there there are
a lot of options here I'm not really
sure once the bus I mean I can call
display Knight e3 he'll probably play h4
here I would assume we now have three
he'll take exchange I mean I probably
could have gotten something a little bit
better than this but it's definitely not
bad
it's an awful pressure on h4 try to
exchange the dark square bishop because
there's only comp areas that he is to
fish so that's literally the only
compensation for pot I'll take the pawn
rook us three Andrew 7 complete workup 1
yeah - if g4 I'll just take take the
take the up on in fact you might have to
play g4 there might not be any other
options from here on f5 all this take so
can I'll obviously go for this and this
is a wishful thinking he's trying to do
something I'll just sidestep it with
kimchi 1 here you go chief world stage
for g3 um I'll just take this isn't
really how I wanted to play this I mean
I've given him a lot more counter play
than he should have gotten but I still
should be winning here and now he's
probably getting needed over here when
he takes I can maybe run King you - I
don't want to take that risk
[Music]
whoops that was a blunder and that's not
going to get it done
all right one more and that's it let's
see so Bishop g5 a couple different ways
it's all just played Queen c7 which
these days is considered to be the best
as far as I know
c4 the cast as well probably 95 on a5 I
think it's not conserved us
95 is a problem here because when he
takes I'll play Knight seat takes e4 and
I'll I'll hit the hit the button
on c4
so I guess my back now or something I'm
a little bit confused as to what just
happened
so there should be seven
it takes P to take stakes or p1
you
I see 7b8 of 9555
I might have just tricked him can you to
up the rupees five doesn't sound a
little bit messy guy 98 6 I can take on
a 5 I'm going to just take on d5 makes
more sounds problem because here I'm
threatening Bishop e3 so probably it's
played work d1 then I go rookie 5 9 i
net the a5 pawn - so 97 I'll check I'll
take the pawn and it has gotten actually
reasonably interesting again considering
how losses should have been a few moves
ago so we'll see one Bishop d6 not not
so not too trivial actually not easy at
all he can always probably just stack
the exchange he wants to but not so
simple so what will I do well I play
Bishop e3 g5 is also moved I think I'll
just play something simple like King g7
just play a waiting move and now I'll
play Bishop g7 it plays rook e8 so I
have worked chief 5 here I don't know if
it works on Bishop a4 also hopefully
Bishop a4 here try and keep it very
people the pieces somewhere and it's
very confusing set up so it works before
and now I think I go over to 5 or maybe
not when I still have rookie 7 also
actually it's a very strange position so
there should be 3 I think I'll play h4
and they're trying confuse matters
although that was probably a bad move in
fact because now there should be 3 he's
got what rook c6 or somewhere I'm c3 I
can take I can also play like fish who
maybe
please work a so now I can play
I tricked in the action now I got
himself into a mess again
so when he takes mine or should not be
able to take this pawns it's kind of
weird 6 I'm going to try the splasher
yeah
Oh sleep if you're going to draw but ok
what good one up guys frankly hadn't ok
good someone from some real roles here
I'll play Eric now wow that's amazing
wants to play yeah
so you place these six this is not maybe
hopefully e6 and transpose into a Queens
Queens and in something unusual - five -
page four to five different g3 um
ninety-two probably he'll take on do
three probably or he'll take on c3 one
or the other or I'm in F file I think F
five laws Bishop e5 if I remember
cracked list should be slightly uh this
I think that's considered slightly wrong
but I don't have the theory in my head
right off download six O'Rourke f8 so I
can play d5 d6 I have Bishop g7 so it's
not Zura its eighth reason move or h4 I
think h4 makes sounds here
so nine to six I can take on e4 takes on
five and go 92 probably nice he looks
back ninety-six III or 99 chief for
probably a three takes takes Bishop d6
okay now I'll take open up the eighth
off my rook
he can play queen g5 problems I'll just
put my other night ops three again and
now I'll play III it's also when he
counsels he's running into some kind of
to d4 c5 s big attack sir actually if he
doesn't I think it's all Castle face to
tell them where it's in putting a king
is he gonna is he going to actually
Castle queenside or not it's not now go
all-in play d4 c5 cleaver key to to
protect this f2 pawn and I'm going to
play Queen a for next move e5 um click
Queen a for here I can take something
but I think I'll just play Queen a for
because also with the rook now in d2 it
can also swing to the beasts lot it can
swing to be two as well
so EB for I can take with the night I
can take up a pawn but tape of the pawn
who might have Bishop g5 but I think
taking that the night makes in those
sides just to bring another piece closer
to this King so probably have to take on
c5 and then Bishop takes a 6
take I'll take egg six probably he'll
take and maybe flavour up sticks so
broke up six right away I'll take okay
queen bee five or ninety five are both
possible it basically if worked b2b
blocks that the rooks and ninety five
takes away that option 9595 looks like a
good move and now if he plays rook AAA I
can just check them on be five because
there should be six practical move
trying to avoid checkmate so I'll take
his rook home will certainly take back
the Queen and now it's just something a
matter of technique well I'll play King
be one just be able just so I can swing
my other work to the to the Queen side
f4 logical move on I can clean I see two
I can just play rook see one maybe or
nice Knight f3 also but moves don't look
so attractive here so I need to come
with an idea I think I'll play 93 he
takes on III anyway I take on f40 takes
not for I don't have anything special up
okay Queen b3 let's protect the pond pin
the bishop simple track takes probably
work e8 or something or queen g6 now
I'll put my Klingon 82 so I can swing
the other work to be 124 and here do I
have 96 now I don't that's very sad
if you place my tc3 we're clean tz3 say
what so 25 now I have 96 like anything
better
I don't see it right off so I'll go for
Oh actually I can't take sorry I thought
I could take the take the bishop twice
but I'll turn the Queen and Alice right
in this and not hangs v6 all right let's
see the next one
Oh Friday Eric this is Eric not Paquin's
weekly these 400 I'll play now let's see
how it goes I kind of play this super
old line on been a long time since I've
played this line for either color so
I'll play e5 d 594 this is pretty known
theory takes takes Queen D 45 is man
line probably I'll take I'll take push
v3 I'll just play Queen out so try to
play Madden game probably slightly
better for white but should be shouldn't
be anything that dangerous also alkalis
try to make this pawn put on on better
square now f4 is and those that I do not
like at all actually
on things kind of weird doesn't doesn't
feel right does it feel like in the flow
of the spirit of the position because
because now after H if I put upon h4
it's going to have these pawns on the
Kings side that don't don't really have
harmony like he's going to play Bishop
g4 I'll just take play h4 basically that
he could have maneuvered the knight a
little bit better words here he'd end up
with a situation where he's going to put
a bishop on f3 and
once you put the fishpond out three the
bishop can't attack the Deaf by pawn
becomes the strength now rather than a
weakness 91 with the de Loup see what he
wants tonight on e3 to try and create
some pressure along this pawn all
now I'll start remover in my night
Fisher d1 I'll play a 5 so I put plant
the night on on c5 so you guys fish at
c2 I'll put this work on on f6 I put the
other work on I faith and hopefully to
work on on a d1 and now house where I
could start coming up with some ideas so
95 3 I'll sleep I'll try to keep this
now you fix ID in my back pocket on he
is riff d2 here so it doesn't quite work
rook e8 so he goes back rook up story ok
so he's so he got he got scared this
idea this on this 96 idea so he wants to
make sure back up 3 but now I'm just
hung up ha you didn't hang it you can
English play h3 I think I will
although actually I just hung up five
now so it's not clear that was a good
move basically if he takes with the Jeep
off then I take up four plays worth take
he'll play Knight takes up 4 anyway so
he plays g3 but playing g3 now all my
pawns are very nicely placed now there
there really are no weaknesses so you
want to cheat on me with 95 obvious I'm
not going to fall for that
King b2 also work at face protect the
pawn me try to ruin over this nice and
how try and get it to g4 maybe at some
point and it's position is very garage
ax a so some
now I'll try and do something now 55 so
if you take I'll take 57 can be 8 so it
goes night off to play Bishop g2 rookies
rookies 5 whole to be 6 I have kind of
butchered this little this is not not
quite what I was hoping for
waitwhat since 94 or Bishop e4 or well
when I got a 94 oh you can just take the
bishop likes forgot about that okay ah
that was a bad move
got that oversight on my part okay
Sookie five I mean okay I think I don't
know if I can I'm going to try it and
substance pretty hopeless now it's not
so hopeless maybe there are some drawing
chances now probably actually pretty
good drawing chances
yeah now it's probably this probably
isn't even like losing probably is maybe
even just flat-out better for me now
we're decided to say hey Brooks he's 46
off the roof d1 I just blundered it oh
yeah II that was that that was bad oh
it's just a bad oversight on my part we
could have just put the roof back on the
other side knows nothing so that was
just that oversight anyway so you can
cake cake move the bishop probably off
for putting along these lines on fish
east six to ninety four seven
I'll clap for
hmm take that's pretty even this is not
not very attractive just forgot that he
had some Queen before tracking this line
five on public change pretty dry pretty
dry open 85 probably he'll take or maybe
we'll play work see a therapy 194 will
see one and on c3 this bill is pretty
pretty boring bring my cane closer I'll
protect the pawn maybe plane I see for
now why not
reasonable position not not great but
considering the openings turned out
pretty decently the c5 on I would once
we're taking the 400-450 one takes e4
okay so if laser takes e4 so I can take
and play Knight d6 maybe our takes c3
were fit for a three b6 pretty or take
95 also 95 Knight of 6
um okay let's take six I'll go for the
sign game it's probably probably this is
probably just a dead drop
okay I'll just probably forward to draw
analysis with these two split pawns
black can't realistically expect to win
on yeah it's just should just be a draw
now although if it's going to play g5 he
might make this a little bit more
interesting for me now since maybe I can
get something because now B pushes c4 I
take the pawn and chief out the check in
fact I'll make the premium just in case
he doesn't see it but okay sixteen mm
I'm definitely not going to give them
and draw now although maybe there's
something I can actually do about it
just like that dull
all are working for is not good because
now I'm for c5i is this one I forgot
about this okay so all photos so maybe
we can still get something here the
tasty
some really somehow nuts assad's I'm not
really sure how but somehow he did
[Music]
because now I can touch too close that
was a very strange game okay I'm not
I'll please five I'll try to take this
seriously by the Berlin D 365 of the
Taebaek should be something moderately
interesting at least for people who are
interested in theory on this is one way
of defining just to take on each of the
Knights once his next move I'll promo
certain little h6 or f6 SS names right
basically played g3 wants to do
something for at some point on now here
I think I want to play Queen instead I'm
just going to wait for him to decide
what he's doing because I might go long
here fact I think I think I will go
along why not and maybe he'll be like
Fischer and take the pawn I doubt it
somehow well this is kind of dangerous
but I have some h5 g 5h fors coming my
king is not really open over here and
because he's played this move g3 there
are some lurking dangers I'll take 94 I
think I can play Bishop g3
yeah why not if you take that cake and I
temple is clean and when you take I take
the knight and this is worked out
beautifully
so probably oh he's not going to take
off in 96 maybe clean a for Queen 80486
but again it's just a clean pond here my
clean site is very safe so this is
looking quite good looking promising at
least so I can try to exchange rooks I
can try to play on the king but I think
probably trying to expand here let him
dictate whether he wants exchange all
the rooks make sense
maybe h4 now h4 repeat work d8 orders p6
many options many many many options here
let's see so what makes the most sense
there I think I'll play g6 g5 I think
I'll play cheese 5 try to expand
probably he'll take on ba maybe not
I think it's rook b8 and it takes Kart
just keep the rope on a chase so I can
play for h4 or catch one maybe Knight f7
try and hit him with 96 on the tempo
also Knight protects the rook up its
queen bee for now I can play rook da
cleaning for NCI just play a stupid move
for no the reason her peers like it
Queen d4 okay so he's offering a
repetition I'm not going to take it
obviously be sixteen be solving create
some extra squares for my king but now
in a four x lyric d8d a queen C for
nineteen be seven eight five eight okay
so this is not a little bit tricky so if
I play ninety-six probably he has to
play off three probably yeah I think
I'll play 96 or did I just hang tv5 oops
oops oops oops be sharper all right I'll
take I mean so much better if it has
kind of gotten a little bit where I
didn't want it to be there's about four
plane I see slide maybe yeah I think
I'll play nice slice on a five I play 96
house take this is kind of tricky so
sawlogs hopefully we need five maybe or
26 it's definitely not not easy at all
now I can also just take the pawn which
looks really really weird but I think I
will but it's a pawn after on d5 was
quickly running into cleanup sighs so I
mean I feel like probably I'd messed
this up this isn't probably winning now
but who wants to play one of these end
games but I wasn't so sure these enemies
are actually are actually drawn because
I have these weak pawns but they are
actually quite good at both attracting
my king ambhi coming and is running
right down the board
like here easy actually can't protect
his paws it's probably gonna have to
like do something where we both get
queens now he goes like G for something
the Queen d3 also guards the Phoenix
where which is very important here some
girlies manages survive which doesn't
feel right
so queen b1 g7 Queen c2 g7 I mean I
guess I have to go for this this is only
what I wanted to do but so Oh false flag
and said when all sales and you can't
play good just to flag them alright
hopefully for again C probably five
maybe wants like Sicilian okay I'll just
play Bishop g5 see what he has a four
this has become very classical recently
all these addition to five games most of
them featuring myself for max and by
Sheila Grodd probably work c8 maybe e6g
six I've seen but I don't feel like it's
uh well let's just say in a blitz game
is going to be hard to play this
correctly play something safe teen b1
now I'll play Queen d2 maybe 22 laws be
for nine days for not really ideal I'll
play Knight b3 zombie for I can meet be
forward 95 which I think makes the most
sense
probably Knight f6 maybe not not also
sure what I'll do there so it plays e6
now I can play this e4 and you plays up
five or something and if I play there
any good sacrifice maybe I can just sack
it's not what I would do ordinarily I
wouldn't do this I don't care though
tonight at six
I can play up five I can also maybe take
or just like Queen d3 - maybe Queen d3
make some stunts or does it in 95 play
this is turned out this is really not
what I was hoping for on stage III hope
that he blunders here which is always
possible the problem should be winning
for black I'm in a computer when this
would put its eyes closed so we're key
eight okay if I play Queen g6 he wants
to go in IC 3 or something something
weird I guess I'll go all allow it
anyway just in case E he goes for
making sure to slaver Cusick factionists
may be a better option but it's all in
the past now although here I do both I
do not have two pawns two cons from the
UH the T is 93 which allows me to take
d6 I guess or actually just take away I
can take as work on a no wait what are
you doing what are you doing Eric what
are you doing that's yeah that was
unfortunate for Eric okay
so play another one another berlin kind
of thing so like we played this the
other day actually
probably Bishop g5 93 'if I've is also a
movie 595 doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense
okay so Eric please clean see to a
reasonable move um there should be seven
maybe a bad move actually that might
allow some kind of g5 95 stuff maybe not
really clear ok so it plays in 83 I'll
play c5 just try and open up the
diagonals for my bishops just like I
think 93 probably was wrong so now on d5
I can place c4 in place just each second
display h6 stop Bishop g5 but I think
it's more important that I uh that I
open to open this long diagonal on the
on the king push v3 now I can play b4
here then he could play Knight e4 rookie
for b6 I don't see it right off so I
think I'll go for it if you take from
getting this very weird on structure on
take c b6 it's kind of really strange 94
ricky for he plays Bishop e6 rook e1 or
if he one takes 24 the b5 ei for I'm in
the hole 84 d5 falls so okay so so he's
going to go for exact take Reese is
really strange pawn structure I mean I
don't know if I should play b5 or not
but maybe I should sack even what about
what about maybe it's time for the
brilliancy maybe it's time to win some
Burlington prize okay let's flip see
this is very interesting because these
I'm saying that I work on this night are
just terribly placed here so he's gonna
put a Queenie - I'm going to take on up
three and I'm going to
these pawns are dominating his night so
cleanup for all cake
hopefully cleanup 3 obviously and now
I'm saying that he can't lose the night
ends rook is stuck and I'm just going to
go see Tori maybe I don't know if this
works or not but it's simply it's worth
a shot of course maybe I'm just insane
and maybe it's no good at all maybe
maybe it's trying to be a genius isn't
the right idea because actually this
doesn't look good at all now
so c3 take d3 maybe c4 on let's say so
a5 eat it he's just going to take yes
I'll play 5 anyway I don't see anything
better my job report 992 I think I'm go
for seats right now
I think 92 is a bad move I think if he
played maybe just King up 1 or maybe
just some explorer he would have been
fine now and I mean now he's going to
get himself into something not not I
mean what's still probably winning but
it's not trivial anymore so it's
probably enough it should be enough to
win here I would think so let's clean up
for okay definitely move on to page 6
White's still probably winning but this
isn't how I mean do without a lot of
time on the clock this is not the ideal
scenario for sure
so please work c7 but now he's going to
not going to give me I'm going to give
me a third pawn to and now probably the
best we can hope for is a draw and
considering the time situation I think
it's fairly unlike although we found ID
1 which is a very good move it's a very
very nice nice move by Eric um so how to
flag and I guess it's the question
okay so final AG picking up again let's
just figure this one out
all right so let's see it okay so far
mostly something different this time
I'll play v3 I forgot Eric disguise you
actually studies d3 theory which is
really annoying I don't know why anyone
would waste their time on that but Eric
for whatever reason feels the need to
prepare for v3 so obviously the looks of
this efore nonsense which is rather
annoying but that's slice h5 strange
move okay so I can tink on f6 and play
Knight c3 and again maybe eric has
actually looked at this I I don't spend
my time preparing v3 so okay so I can
take the pawn if I want I don't think I
will I can click Queen e2 also or maybe
even sf3 h4 takes Queen due to the night
f2 very weird I don't really like it so
I'll just I'll council right into the
storm although maybe that was a bad mood
on h4 if I take he is up slide now that
was probably really bad decision but he
plays difficult for of like weaning one
404 92 yeah this is pretty pretty
terrible though so there should be six
um now I have to find some way to not
lose on a spot maybe 19e for fish s3
maybe somehow takes take up 325 F G for
play choking off to and I survive I
think somehow yeah I don't actually see
how it loses right away I'm sure it's
losing somehow but it doesn't seem to me
to be losing right away look each three
I can go virtue one
or even Knight f4 possibly Knight f4
with the idea of rich one if he takes I
take h3 night of four bush before EF
Hornets check on the King so this is
actually not all that clear right off
air can obviously play district g3 and
he's definitely better on on this one I
think I go G size zero Knight f4 was
also there to um but I I like tree five
because now you know it hits the rock
eyes work h1 coming next from the list
not not not all that clear blacks
obviously much better but it's not not I
I would say winning on the spot now I'm
Bishop g3 I can also just move my King
up one Square and if you lose his Queen
I don't eat five maybe night at four or
two five or gauge for it's obviously all
very terrible still but it's not it
could be worse now I'm play what will I
do here okay so I broke it out of play
that's priority number one
my pieces over here are not ideal so
I'll taking G one get my king out of the
out of the line of fire first and see
what I can do it's still dad but maybe
it's not terrible of course if Eric's
not really quick here on like whoops I
can't move my ugly work be one if Eric's
not quick here if I can get some stuff
Rick you want to Queen B to Eric's not
super quick here I can get some kind of
consolidation this this might be
relatively ok so I'll play what will I
do here to clean up to maybe make sense
now
oh that just a lot of work up five maybe
yeah he can play Queen because I kind of
couldn't really protect everything over
here though to begin with so I'm not all
that unhappy with him going going to
grab over here
split up sighs I don't understand what I
five the jaws the work age three protect
upon knives d for coming d4c five maybe
okay so now he has a plan you want to
play cheese five this I can understand
but aunty fires I might have night g6
and Queen take off five so he's still
it's like hanging on the edge it's like
the edge between being like okay and
just being outright loss so I'll play d4
try to force his hand a little bit and
because we took on a four oh you can
just take h3 I forgot about that yeah
thought is a genius there that didn't
quite work what you just declined into
decline or D when you disconnect is that
all right I'll play someone else and
I'll play this reacting guy I guess you
disconnected I don't know what what
happened there anyway I'll play someone
else now I think I play this guy
recently I think he's I think I played
him actually last night of the Knockouts
in fact
it's officially foresaw three it's all
pretty standard 1955 is not standard I
think form of those lock takes is the C
pawn or the e pawn probably takes takes
there should be seven I think on each
here is something similar to this forget
which switches on it was B is something
pretty similar to this so there should
be six hopefully g3 I don't want to take
the knight as long as there's a rook on
the H file
hasil now I'll play now I can take by
what I think I do actually want to take
so I'll just take and plate u54 try
attack prime for trying to do something
here maybe beat something each for
maybe just go all and just try to attack
and said probably C 5 H 5 something like
this g5 I'll play f4 filled up the
center consolidated is no sax here like
on a on you claw it'll take probably six
all that opens up a default for the
rooks and maybe you won't want that so
Queen b6 reasonable move I don't want it
to attack so I don't really want to
exchange but I'll play positional sakip
lady size because if I take any takes
pawn structures not so great
although maybe after deep I see a clean
D forum we need for Chuck maybe I'm not
sure where it's here I'm down upon but I
also have good my bishops are good his
weakness on d5 and it's not actually so
bad here I mean f5 is too loose includes
be $45 they kini to probably single
again if he goes a six level Bishop e3
hitting the night when the Knights under
attack the pawns under attack on e5 so
everything is kind of slowing down
position all the pieces are in harmony
whereas he repeated opponent uses up on
d4 and hit a knight on d5 would be a
totally different story so Bishop c5 and
now I'll click in b3 take landing Bishop
g4 maybe plan up five here or B for work
a5 a lot of different possibilities here
a six okay so now I'll play with each c1
and now the thing goes we're creating
night run into this stage 3 because on
Roxy 7 I'd be 4 and the pen on the rook
on works we fix it will be for anyway I
want to most efficient I'm going to
exchange the rooks now I didn't see
Bishop up to I guess his fish bait for
here but all this tape upon
so now I'll see what what is not
someone's going to do so please we're p8
I guess again lost point is before I
think the top five maybe and now it's 94
just take the pawn because when tonight
before work loose it's 92 okay it
doesn't matter too if you played
something else the King f8 also digits
c3 I probably want to go Fischer deform
exchange because this night the night
also to the bishop is uh not so great I
think you just hung up on okay see had
an idea so you want to go with your
cheese okay it had a good idea okay so
I'll play King before the mover rook c5
of the move I guess rook c5 takes 45
Knight e3 would be four I don't know if
that's enough to win but I'll try it
okay what nice be sick now if you look
because this is pretty bad just the
bishops are too strong
tonight Bishop we work night vision for
all I'm not coordinated here so there's
some big problems it's very hard to talk
everything so with dat for I don't see
how you protect the fish man a knight
now is for this would be for for
domination and I guess I could play rook
a5 and just stick up tonight Wow okay so
let's see
now the remembers oh I got pins over
something at 3:55 play Queen cm declines
one game come on play something a little
bit different or not if he's going to
play three three three two castles
castles and I could do something right
for something aggressive as I can
so 93 92 and probably for here maybe e4
c5 trying to spice it up a little bit
and anywhere a probably he'll take on d5
I mean if he doesn't if you take on c5 d
4 is pretty good
TIG sticks I guess you can teach me 6
maybe or you can play 95 put you slides
here try to make it really complex and
messy DS sensible different cheese pies
you Forbush feature so I really want to
hit him with up lies I get a chance
thank you 7 over b8 its nicely c5 and
now ok so now if I pleat b6 he'll play
C's six maybe c6 Knight c5 or c6 Knight
out nice if I take to Queen c5 so that's
no good
so I can play Knight f6 maybe pawn here
is it without 5c is 96 so if I can
alleviate that concern and then I should
be fine on course it's going to be very
hard to do that so I'll just play King
h8 something practical
v4 that's fine play retreat now I want
to go out 5 4 so it's my whole whole
concept probably pretty pretty bad
objectively but it is once again so now
I'm going to now I'm going to watch I'll
go e4 and I'm going to click the III
it's not not so simple now for a for
either side actually
it's 3d 3d now I have a big pond chained
to here so even though he is a punching
we both got and objectively what we
wanted so queens before I think Queens
before it's probably not right this
applause 95 now I'll go clean up six now
I'm trying to get some activity in this
kind of once I start to get activity
eventually to Bishop should be should be
quite good here
please 94 now I can play b6 maybe b6 c6
and work d8 or something crazy but I'll
just play classical there should be
seven an idea Bishop c6 v sighs now I
can play d2 maybe or I can play
something random maybe riff BD 8 or work
I'll put the other work on d8 maybe the
point is if you place these six I'm
going to stack for sure on place 96 now
put up the rook e8 the rook c8 basically
I'm trying to confuse them a little bit
here making me some time get them a
little bit confused do you really want
to do the NCS it's hard van spawns as
well so if we both have some some play
here so I'm going to try and play for d2
and 93 try and really make this messy
now as much as I possibly can again this
should be objectively fat c6 I can play
take maybe four maybe or am I just in a
lot of trouble here um so okay so if I
play Knight before Queen c5 take take
takes rook c6 Queen d7 or PA okay so
this seems a reasonable so I'm going to
stack on c6 now on
now Queen d7 I've worked the ADA he
moves away then I take the pawn I've got
two pieces of art on two-piece life
coupons which is exactly what I wanted
so now we put the way you played this
though you gave me options so now I can
now I can definitely get something going
95 allows some Oh a lot of many things
I'll just leave cheese pies North before
so that g4 ff4 it's very important F for
actions might be my next move so it
plays F for himself play III I can also
just take ya 28 cakes my lychee fund
then I go eater in and this is pretty
ugly probably work a threes the only
move makes sense if you can try broke up
one I didn't really expect that honestly
Bishop g7 force him to move the rook to
d1 so they're wise it Queen after rook
e1 that I'll just play with ACA for now
I've got lots of compensation here
probably in fact too much I'll put it ok
3 protect upon and I'll start running
this con down the board to fact actually
I don't have much time here do I
ah terrible
very strange that was very strange
[Music]
all right so it's all playing he3 here
the e5 Knight a5 idea please repeat b3
fish should be - pretty standard stuff
um not sure is he thinking or okay so he
is
maybe he'll play Bishop a three maybe
maybe not
it shows not to rook d8 maybe it still
want to play for c5 or eise i of i'll
play mostly Bishop e2 CD for play Knight
takes d4 95 Queen e2 or Knight d5 Queen
c2 also as possible so we take some
cheats for it up to strange sir I'll
take 95 22
a six maybe
rookie one try and hit the Queen force
to clean off the square then I'll play
with d1 or beef or maybe also as a
possibility
Queen e8 he wants to keep the a for
square as I'll play rook d1 tack Knight
f5 might be an idea might be in the key
word could be for Knight a for C size or
97 it's strange we focus C 586 so
basically wants plot the knight on c4
logical on okay so here I can do many
things I can take funny tips now I can't
so say also play Knight f3 make them
have to move his night and I'll take up
sticks
so this Knight mp4 looks really good
here but it is also kind of not so good
because it it's an outpost but then but
it doesn't really do what you're kind of
a tax pawn in a three but it's out of
the game of a passed pawn here and so
structurally well it looks really pretty
it doesn't serve a very good purpose so
like rook e8 I'll play rook d3 probably
he'll take maybe not
King g7 also as possible but basically
the night here on c4 it looks good but
he compromised the pawn structure in a
way that probably wasn't wasn't ideal
okay 92 so if you want to take the
knight or 495 maybe to take and then
also Queen b6 the problem here is that
most these onions should be losing I
think so if I play up for ya up for this
has to be pretty pretty bad for black
this takes takes 97 94 k-8 and I'm
getting a pawn to c6 so we take I'll
take
97 94 King f8 and I see spot plays 96
off to 94 make sure I tack on
you can't go team ethics at night up six
which means like if you can't run to
chase the pond right away which is
important so you place five and now I
can't eek
okay I'll just take and play nicely
three and this should be winning I would
think it's not going to be easy but it
should be winning so play for protect
that now I'll probably run this way I'll
try to run and pick up this edge pawn
although maybe it's not so simple on an
icy sighs okay so those teenage five so
you have to take the mono cake now he
can't take the push so nice these pies
might not be winning but I'm going to
take a shot just see if I can maybe
windows or not because if he goes
ninety-four ago King g7 go King e7o is
f5 or no I find I go d7 it plays 90s yes
I've obviously d7 he has to take it
might be a draw I'm not sure but I I
know that at least in practice is going
to be very hard because even though I've
doubled pawns they they are quite good
so cheat arena let's see a king very
good night there now I'll push up five
control everything
[Music]
no Keeney six and now this should just
be winning I would think up six but he
can't he can't stop the pawns now
there's there's no blockade and now it's
definitely losing so it's just a
question of being careful here so that's
litchi for that I can't win so play
kingi five trying triangular looking at
14 g5 and now yes now the fact each is a
clog Wow
all right I'll play I think I'll play in
two more games on all place in my house
play something different now on Playa
Playa gingy if you please d5 will you
play d5 and a large in here or not
no he won't how disappointing so I guess
I'll play some kind of a kind of English
or some kind of some kind of accelerator
dragon in some form it takes a kickin
with a deep on is fine but I don't want
an end game 26 so I'll play on I f6e 43
probably are the two moves queen bee
tree looks a little bit weird
hopefully t5 and then well I think I
will take with the night
Tigs I'll take with the cooling make
them expand your everything of the time
game I won't mind this is much more
favorable than the other one play Bishop
a6 make sure you can castle try and
delay as development here
to be three bishops III ah King do you
want interesting okay so now I'll flip
c8 there should be two I'll go Keaney
seven studs the plan probably he'll take
fish up three so I'm dish Buster there's
got to be some way to take advantage of
all these sweets attempt II on but I'm
actually sing it strangely enough what
do I do this so if I play e5 he takes
takes takes d4 actually I think e5 makes
sense here because if you think he'll
play work e8 others would cook okay so
he doesn't want to have any part of this
up it also works e8 and now though if
you plays works if you want to exchange
employee form he's just down upon now he
this is literally just some very weird
endgame I think where he's going to get
a king gt4 but his Bishop is also
trapped for the rest of the game so
after this is king is nice but his
vision is also extract on g2 so he can't
actually move or use used bishop in an
effective manner here so he's trying to
create squares on meaning this is still
okay for white it's very hard to believe
and then maybe it's okay I don't know
kind of hard to believe that this is
okay but I could see it being a draw to
place Bishop g2 okay
so I'll put h6 finally g5 and I'll
anomaly Bishop d1 I think so now I can
need to play up horn and open it up
although you can't get a bishop behind
the pawn um it's kind of not really
perfect but we'll see if I can somehow
find some magic and find a way to win
this on Bishop c8 so I can go III maybe
III takes up three takes Bishop e2 seems
like the right way to try to win here so
I can play e3 takes up three up to now I
can play f3 now I have to go III oh but
it's the wrong color bishop for some
reason I thought it was the right color
bridge oh that was rather unfortunate
I just forgot that is the wrong color
but you never know maybe he is maybe
he'll blonder hair maybe very unlikely
but it could happen
Wow
not really it's rueful wow what wow
what
oh it's only 114 149 122 is pretty
impressive
whoever you are that's uh there's
something wrong with you that's that's
ridiculous that's ridiculous
that's insane um my okay let's see
that's just weird
Wow Wow
maybe I'll try bowling again I don't I
mean there's a lot of lag when I did it
okay never mind open to this guy stuck
the georgian armenian guy gets the flat
five looks like georgia is Armenian
actually but anyway okay so a six cups
of fun play some gambit style chest this
would be for gambit declined that's very
sad alright hopefully Queen c2 castles
Bishop d2 I want to play g5 but I have
to do it the right moment
play e3 there should be three necks
maybe he'll just ignore maybe want to
take maybe I'll just play 94 here I'm
completely just ignore it which would be
rather funny okay so now he's going to
play DC 45 this is kind of what I was
hoping for some kind of similar I'm
getting some attack on campus so
probably he'll take and play b5 Bishop
d3 something along these lines or c5
also between v3 maybe g6 h4 and then I'm
trying to place them in a little bit
silly this kind of long looks more like
to evolve the style than anything else
8e 5 6 so if I take take take Queen d5
so if I Cape at the pawn he'll take the
night so I mean why not just go for why
not just play h5 all and just just just
made him
take selfie heck if you place work up
seven and I've work h7 you lose the King
I take with check this is pretty ugly
I'll play we'll take the x7
so Queenie 7 I think I just take on g6
and just brutal I'm just really weird
all that was pretty ugly well it's a
night of three I'll play dodge I'll play
dodge this my turn it is some kind of
English so he ends up playing like d3 if
you please d4 I'll stay true but if you
please d3 yeah it's going to turn it
some kind of English I guess if you
please g3 here yeah it's just going to
turn to a standard English so there's a
g5 okay sake has its position against I
think Artemia maybe and I'm in the world
Blitzen rapid I think it was known
variation 56 probably it'll go Knight f4
I'll go CH 7 take take or maybe rook e1
here or b5 I guess um make some sense in
with Bishop d7 maybe I'm not crazy about
positions that have gotten into probably
just Bishop d7 but let's see maybe just
actually I'll just play Queen do
something because here he plays rook e1
I've work a two strange position quite
strange
look you won or k2 maybe so Queen f3
also reasonable move monthly work a6 to
protect the pod so really the issue I
have here is that my although do I have
initially Bishop a7 now now rupee to and
now I'll offer repeat and then I'll
change my mind
okay so he clearly wants he doesn't mind
repeating Oh Queen c7 might allow some
96 maybe something really weird
maybe Queen 8 southern makes on sea
rocks yeah maybe just Queen a7 now I'm
rookie 1 I can play this would be 6 I
think as you moves to rip away than all
the g5 dish musics complete my
developments alright so you did play
with you once now I think if you played
Bishop d6 I don't see why this doesn't
work maybe I'm going to lose
spectacularly but I don't I don't
actually see it here I mean probably
we're going to end up in some enemies in
a sack out he's going to just take on
Visa couldn't take on a second probably
still pretty good drawing chances but
it's going to be a interesting it's an
IE 6 okay so this move I did see um now
if I T and I play King g7 I think I'm
just really good here because okay c5 so
we saw that I was gonna play Bishop us
to but now I think I can if I take what
what is going on here actually so if I
take on c5 Queen c6 to be a big problem
actually so you might have just not a
really nice idea this could be a slight
problem so if I take on c5 he plays
Queen c6 I take I'm in big trouble
I take and play Queen c7 or if I just
play d5 maybe and maybe I just have to
play d5 and just admit that something's
gone badly wrong here not really ideal
but such as lies
maybe King takes off a 26-bit should be
stuffing was also possible no no I hung
the p7 here there's something better
than this I'm not actually sure okay
there takes I'll take so lunch or some
end you know ah so now he's cleaning
through here
ah you can take these clean eh at
follows rather nice yeah I should I
should not have played it like this I
should have played it slightly
differently I could have taken 26 fish
base up and was probably the correct way
to play it
that was not not very smart
anyway I'll be right back everybody can
run to the restroom on a second after
this game ends on so okay
Wow
what Wow
what what wow
what Wow what Wow
Wow
okay I think I'll play something like
someone at the top again one thing I
don't like is playing these guys for
like 2,600 where you get like +2 for
when and I use like 15 if you play a bad
game I just want it frustrating after a
while let's see is Eric here still no or
is he
unclear or actually okay I'll play this
game guy again I guess if there's no one
else out what Oh what
oh I thought I said sit on oh wait what
am i playing this normal Chester this
gam is this a giveaway or normal all
right look oh okay this is very strange
I'm confused by what has happened here
on
okay that was very strange
all right this pretty random random
nonsense
the 93 maybe probably also 56 put H 4 5
Bishop d3 say something weird try and
create something probably he'll take
maybe not or Queen c7
so he keeps refusing to take so then it
may have to play some Carl Kahn
structure but this should be should be
good to e4 97 all the e5 @ 4 that h sx h
h5 h6 structure that should be quite
good for white um I kind of don't I kind
of want to castlelong ready we'll go
short and play rook e1 maybe although I
just added some kind of f5 maybe which
was a little bit unnecessary perhaps but
I'll take an oh he took the Jeep on
interesting I thought it would take up
the with a knight now I think I might up
flies and this shouldn't pretty good
Queenie 1196 some take takes rook e6
looks looks to be good I'm not sure if
it is
um yes 90 16 mm I'll take take me six
night at the a broke up six looks pretty
pretty disastrous um
and anything else I just put a knight on
outside and the night is just so
beautiful
it can't be touch they're all these
weaknesses try to apply with pawns and
have sex on that age six is just so nice
in fact it also I control the e-file as
well so this pretty much is already over
now I can even just play repeats topping
on top at this position us four o'clock
right and you can just I can even just
exchange all the all of all D on all the
rough administers terrible oh yeah oh
I'm not surprised e resigned not okay so
hopefully something different very
different at that
okay so I think I confuse them a little
bit so 92 I'll play vision 57 3d6
probably Bishop e2 maybe vision v3 I'll
play h5 now the question is c5 or e5 e
5y me cuz I wanna play e5 s5 so I guess
I'll play e5 c5 d5 is also fine but I
really want to put this pawn here on f5
and this is the c5 d 5 structure no not
as good not as attractive
so I'll just play off 5 anyway so he
wants to exchange on the page cloud
which is flying because he's what he's
kind of behind in development a little
bit so when to when he offers to
exchange I mean yes it probably created
Queens now so I get me 4 he's probably
just in a lot of trouble so there should
be 2 I'll play on something p6 not my
ideal move here certainly but seems
reasonable not now all bring my King
back to e8 with this one 357 see on e4
f4 always I just want to develop my
knight like fish beat 697 is the ideal I
didn't nice next to move big fish about
3 I plead gf okay especially 697 pretty
pretty boring pretty equal but still the
game goes on up for interesting play 97
all item exchange on e5 maybe on a King
off 7 he has this page 5 King FA still
seems fairly balanced I would say I can
probably take and I can just take the
bishop h5 f king of 8 and if he
exchanges I mean again not a whole lot
is happening here but the game goes on
tonight at 5 I did not act I actually
overlooked this this also takes it takes
King up 6 or King e6 I guess this is
not really what I was hoping for
actually I said I think I'd blunder I
think take a knee for might've an
extremely strong but anyway you should
see three so he's trying to play here
I'll play ninety-seven I guess or not or
rook da maybe just very equal
unfortunately just very boring I'm games
so now I've 94 I'll go king d7 Knight f4
I'll probably go to b7 anyway
I guess he has rook e1 now I kind of mmm
kind of overlooked that clipped it so if
I go King c8 96 so Kimmy 896 King f8 96
Kim GA check looks like I'm holding on
not by much mind E but maybe or maybe
I'm not holding on at all actually I
think work h1 was winning now after work
you one I sold 96 and I still can
pretend to fight on probably still very
bad but maybe it's not completely lost
maybe very hard to know but okay so
night of course I can just take I think
96 I can take or chew 16,000 so probably
he'll take on cheese so code thing
Knight f5 play rook c8 for this Bishop
update make sure there are no checks
anymore now I can just regroup bring my
king to F stop maybe actually I just
cloudy sighs okay
now I kind of have this television
although these Chinese each one to win
this somehow seems rather unlikely is
going to win this but if you just wonder
the night
okay now this gets interesting oops
alright so I'll place like two more
times
what's going to do fishing p4 p5 says
gonna play like penguin
okay this is very classical um which way
to take I'll take with the night this is
probably not the best but I'll go for it
96 I'll take line 82 probably play see
for next move tonight a three time to
take Queen a one Queen b6 now I can play
like 95 maybe Bishop d4 actually the 54
makes a lot of sense if you take that
rookie won't concede or thought it rook
e1 Queen c2 maybe I'm insane a good
chance I'm actually just insane um so
you please clean b7 I play like rook c1
maybe fish about five and I'll play like
95 maybe or take still not a whole lot
or it's very hard to create much play so
I'll just play 92s and I'm okay I can
play Queen to probably say for some fish
buff three try to put some pressure on
these these pawns here
not ideal but it's the start to h3h pie
like plate g4 here but I don't really
like it I think I'll just play this
repertory just play simple shots maybe
force him to play Bishop e6 and I'll
flip the toilet so I broke it okay one
does not do anything he just takes so if
I take on a3 I take on d5 and I feel
like beef or maybe this is the way for
it I'll take take and I'll play b4 and
I'll try to run this outside pass on
straight down the boards or okay to open
IV 394 I'll take maybe g4 or I can just
take maybe just take the simplest so now
I can play up three or work c7 all right
f3 rupee - maybe is a problem 9450 296
maybe maybe just work c7 just simple
trust
probably spill it - rather Brooke before
work e7 maybe there's some some help is
a little something
b5 is surprising move the seats now I
can go 97 t4 that's like what is going
on there ok so d force of I think he
takes on e3 if I play up 3 bish +5 no
out 3 d3 so I kind of have to take salt
take probably can do it I'll take now I
can take 2 to take b4 take you to
and I didn't see that woof not good okay
so now if we try to swindle him on time
or something ridiculous so just see what
I can do
well why this Nike for trip was not not
really through best thing to do so
obviously it's a draw but
oh wow so chief 5 Oakland so I can play
murky so forth to draw and I don't
really see what I'm doing with rogue a7
but it'll be a draw sound
it's just how it goes rook b5 Wow
so I'm really kind of confused by what's
going on in this game ok he's going to
play like this maybe I have to kind of
force it draws on huh I guess I am is
shocked
or is going to play out oh good I don't
really understand what's going on in
this game but yeah okay so I'll play
it's got two more and that's it
so I'm playing something really weird
full see what he was going to do how
he's going to react to it I'll defy of
interesting itself in 95 so you just
gave me a free square which is
interesting in c8 don't clean you
telling I don't want some fish bait or
not softly five I'll take up to 96 or
play 96 interesting play those classics
okay seven maybe you'll play off for
maybe not take I don't know why I just
took enough for that was kind of stupid
work out for and play 96 also just play
night ups 9s 11 hangs upon okay so now u
6h for an hour play Queen e8 try to pick
up this pawn here now here I could play
f5 that that is a reason we're trying
talk I think I will do it just to cut
off to cut the diagonal on I do with 94
here as well so I did pick the poison I
want on 94 Queen d2 this does not look
good so I take EF v g5 rookie for I just
take a but I can also just take maybe
I'm just take on a5 with a pond
one deceased size 22 maybe just f4 King
g7 it's pretty terrible but let's see
clicking g7
so teen each one really has time to just
waste and move so I efficient cheat
district g3 is clean see throughout this
may be just queen g6 is 97 I've queen g3
threatening me and already maybe it's
not so clear so existed
alright so queen d3 now can I go Queen
g3 here and just I probably can but I
don't to the point I think rook e8 his
work on h4 is really stupid here so I
don't really see the point to doing that
so it takes I take on what is he
threatening so Queen e2 so I've 94 for
example which i think is really strong
so when this all went really wrong for
him I'll click Queen g5 probably clean
up to 6 just to get rid of this very
annoying pod +4 just what box in the
rook now completely this rook is just
stuck here the Queen half to protect it
ok three notes take this pawn here on c4
and this is pretty much lost I think so
the Queen e1 okay reasonable move to try
and create something else flavor eh just
to double the rook on the thief I'll
probably at some point on I think I can
just take yeah I can just take this on
clock 24 over t1 so okay one more and
then I think I'll pick someone all
placed on them to run random one locks
clicking 6.8 so you keeps - a 6-1 again
I'm going to come image this works so
well the first time I might as well do
it again to see size and all for G size
probably cakes taking something weird
again probably nice e5 probably but I
don't know for sure
b4 probably is bad no no I'm just giving
a free pawn but again he doesn't seem to
want to free pause so I'm just going to
exchange probably King be a 95 or 92
well here this isn't so clear because
this King now ideated I mean it's
completely fine but II four is weak g7
is weak he hasn't developed any pieces
really and I'm going to castle next move
without a doubt so I'm quite so simple
so 97 ofus no I'm definitely in a castle
make him take on d2 step 1 oh he doesn't
watch me wants to continue Sevenoaks all
take on e4
she ate an LP for trying to try and hit
this Bishop force it off the square
please if I probably play a three uh
maybe goes there then now I was this big
Chuck on a three and this looks pretty
pretty terrible
maybe Bishop c4 9600 skip the bishop on
c4 seems logical
defilers take up seven D one and put
mixing on b-17 maybe 95 96 let's move
ta-take cake
I'll check King up seven and I'll take
on d7 and it should be lost
so I've rookie seven chuckling okay so
what gets the last game okay so it now
this is not what I meant
okay I'll guard its last game these six
hopefully this looks sorta clean I have
three okay let's work out anyway terms
the same thing g5 hi there captures
final think of the night this is a
slightly perplexing five so we for I'll
click going to seven I'm going to play
with P 848 and night I paid puts my plan
or actually this also actually bullet
game so on okay so I need to be a little
bit quicker
probably rookies here 2223 also one-time
gift should be women slip-on same color
bishops 1/4 bad mix that actually
creates a big week I'll play this way
just to make sure the views I didn't
have to play this up well he's going to
hang upon them pretty much so yeah
alright you guys so I think um I think
I'll stop for now um I'll be back again
soon and I hope you guys all enjoyed it
and we look forward to next time
hopefully I'll play a little bit better
when I did today didn't play
fantastically but I hope I hope everyone
enjoyed it on the left so have a good
day everybody